bình chỉ 3 nhất mà bật đi tới
quả trình ra ở lợp của bật đi từ bị chỉ bây giờ này
để bị chỉ bình chỉ là bây giờ này
chỉ tà nổi
bật ra ở lợp nhiều quả
bật thì phân tích như là lợp như bật là chuyện đậu gì nhất
khi bật bật đi từ bị chỉ quyền
đi về bị chỉ cần mặng o,
thì chuyện đậu này là chuyện đậu ngang dần
chuyện đậu ngang dần
với Đệnh bị chỉ cần mặng o
có chuyện đậu nghĩ đậu nữa
thì chuyện đậu này là chuyện đậu
chắc ra
đi từ Cooperated bị chỉ cần mặng o
bật chuyện đậu ngang dần
nhưng ăn ra
rồi, thì chỉ cần mặng o
chuyện đậu này là chuyện đậu
chắc ra
có thể nói sao là yêu có ngoài một hai chuyện đậu
là chuyện đó, Nen zân của chuyện đó, chất danh
Phải kì bản chất của giá lỗi người hoàn tụi đặc,
là đi là
Nếu một vận mất nhau lọc nhiều quả, thì nó sẽ có một phương trình
1 bản, a  1, bốt
Ờ, oxy mâu biệt lạ tên trong phí
Em là bản, chất của giá lỗi người hoàn tụi